У Німеччині - близько 80 мільйонів велосипедів.
Майже стільки ж, як мешканців.
Приблизно 260 тисяч велосипедів щороку крадуть.
Більшість ніколи не знаходять.
Один з небагатьох винятків - е-байк, який придбали в цій крамниці в Берліні.
Це Winora, з низькою посадкою і приводом Bosch.
Велосипед жінки, який вкрали, був червоного кольору.
Він коштував 2 599 євро.
Вона купила його в нас у січні 2020 року.
А вкрали його в червні-липні 2020-го, коли у їхньому будинку
були будівельні роботи. Зламали замок у підвалі й викрали велосипед.
Розслідування DW з'ясувало, що вкрадений у німецькій столиці електровелосипед
сплив в Україні, у Дніпрі. Ми зателефонували покупцеві вкраденого байку.
Голос (по телефону) "Я прийшов у крамницю. Я його побачив, випробував. І купив."
Кор:-А скільки він коштував?
Голос: 26 тисяч.
Кор: - А скажіть, будь ласка, якісь документи вони Вам надали або чек?
Голос: Жодних. А чек - так, надали.
А документів на сам велосипед на кшталт технічного паспорту - ні.
Велосипеди, вкрадені в Німеччині, часто вивозять контрабандою через Польщу
далі на схід. Дешеві велосипеди - у нерозібраному вигляді.
Дорожчі моделі розкладають на окремі частини та транспортують у мікроавтобусах.
Якщо є підозра на контрабанду, українські митники не можуть звернутися
напряму до західних колег. Адже запити потрібно робити через мін'юст.
Надто багато бюрократії.
На неї скаржиться і Михайло Уманець.
Він продає у Києві велосипеди, які купує в Німеччині оптом.
Переважно у гуртовиків, з якими співпрацює вже тривалий час.
Вони також допомагають з документами, надають поліції та митниці список
із номерами рам велосипедів, договір купівлі-продажу,
документи про здійснення платежів.
Він сам телефонує в поліцію. Тому що йому не потрібні проблеми.
Якщо ми будемо переїжджати кордон і в нас будуть якісь проблеми, то буде офіційно,
в нас є контракт. Якщо в нас будуть проблеми, то і в нього будуть проблеми, відповідно.
Михайло Уманець продає здебільшого менш дорогі або вживані велосипеди.
Адаптується до купівельної спроможності своїх клієнтів.
Електровелосипеди по 2-3 тисячі євро нам невигідно купувати,
тому що є конкуренти, які крадені такі велікі
по 500-600 євро. Тому нема сенсу в цьому.
Тим часом у Німеччині поліція звернула увагу, що крадуть дедалі більше
дорогих велосипедів. І мало кого з крадіїв вдається спіймати.
Проблема в тому, що якщо велосипед вкрали, у нас навряд чи є якісь "зачіпки".
Дуже низький коефіцієнт розкриття, менше 10 відсотків, свідчить про це красномовно.
Свідків цього виду злочину немає. Якщо хтось серед білого дня відчепить велосипед
у громадському місці, жодна людина цього не помітить.
Це одна з причин, чому крадуть так багато велосипедів: їх важко убезпечити від крадіжки.
При цьому поліцейським добре відомо, як діють крадії.
Хороші злочинці зазвичай працюють групами по троє-четверо: один шпигує,
по смартфону передає, де стоїть хороший, цікавий велосипед.
Потім приходять двоє, які "зачищають" місцевість,
а тоді наостанок приїздить транспортер.
На той момент вони вже знають, який на велосипеді замок.
На практиці немає жодного замка, який би не могли зламати крадії. Питання лише в інструменті.
Ви можете лише максимально ускладнити завдання злочинців.
Ми говоримо про часовий проміжок. Чим довше правопорушники провозяться,
тим більший ризик виявлення крадіжки. Інколи ми рекомендуємо використовувати
два замки. Залежно від того, де стоїть велосипед.
Але і поліцейський визнає, що іноді ніщо не допомагає.
Бувало, велосипеди крали буквально під вікнами відділку поліції.